from action-packed timey wimey sci fi
adventurer's to a surreal journey
through the human mind these are the
shows you should be watching in 2018
throw some popcorn in the microwave and
dig out your binge-watching sweatpants
because we're diving in HBO's True
detective broad cary fukunaga has worked
to a mainstream audience his keen eye
for cinematography was a key component
of the show's season one success after
that he released beasts of no nation
which was met with similarly positive
critical acclaim
then he more or less disappeared for
three years before blazing back to the
small screen with maniac the wait was
worth it
starring Jonah Hill and Emma Stone as
patients in an experimental mental
health study in a retro futuristic
dystopia the beautifully shot maniac
jumps from genre to genre through Owen
and Annie's fantasies and Fukunaga keeps
the focus squarely on the difficulty of
living with mental illness and trauma
and the possibility of finding
connection and community despite for
even because of those issues Donald
Glover and his team had a lot to live up
to when the second season of Atlanta was
announced the show's first season firmly
established it as one of the most
electrifying television series in recent
memory and Glover's performance has
earned in season two of Atlanta
subtitled Robin season is as good as
you'd expect but it also showcases the
other characters with the confidence you
won't see on any other show the season
was filled with standout episodes
highlighting the other characters in the
show like the nightmarish Teddy Perkins
which follows Darius played by Lou Keith
Stanfield meeting a Michael
jackson-esque musician in an ominous
mansion woods on the other hand followed
Brian Tyree Henry's owl aka paperboy as
he's haunted by the downsides of his own
fame and success Huw stand still you're
gone boy you're wasting time and the
only people who get time a day more than
half of the season was directed by Hiro
Mirai Glover's longtime music video
director and Mariah's expert visual
sense and rich use of surrealism has
made Atlanta one of the best looking
shows on television after returning to
television for the first time in 20
years in 2005 doctor who reestablished
itself as a stylish sci-fi show for a
new
audience stills despite multiple
showrunners and multiple actors playing
the eponymous doctor the next decade of
Doctor Who settled into a comfortable
rhythm an eccentric male lead on again
off again romances with various co-stars
callbacks to the original run and silly
science-fiction shenanigans joke old foe
toto
no oh so cold osso bucco Buffalo Joe
that all changed in 2018 when for the
first time a woman took over as the
title character what do we do
why are you asking her but she's in
charge bro Jesu Jodi Whitaker's turn as
the doctor ended up being exactly the
shot in the arm that the show needed
coinciding nicely with new showrunner
Chris Chibnall tenure the haunting of
Hill House is horror at its best
simultaneously terrifying and thrilling
while also dealing with the emotional
core that should be at the center of
every horror movie the richness of
character has led to some reviews
calling Hill House a drama with ghosts
or like this as us wrapped in a gothic
ghost story but make no mistake Hill
House is absolutely terrifying
director showrunner Mike Flanagan
showcases all the technical brilliance
that made oculus and Gerald's game so
profoundly scary and through it all he
never loses sight of the fact that the
ghosts are a way for the audience to
connect to the crane family's trauma
it's just that you know they're all so
scary as hell as the prequel and
sometimes kind of sequel to Breaking Bad
better call Saul takes a bit of a slower
pace than its predecessor but is still
prone to occasional explosions of
violence you're more likely to see
elaborate cons than the vicious meth
heads that populated Breaking Bad but
the underlying moral decay and fantastic
character writing is even better Bob
Odenkirk fills Jimmy with such warmth
and humanity that it's like watching a
horror movie as he slowly loses his last
bits of morality you think I'm some kind
of lowlife some kind of ass what a
lawyer guilty people hire right Jimmy
that's you look at me and you see
slippin Jimmy even for a show is
consistent as better call Saul season
four was a victory lap and took viewers
closer to the events of Breaking Bad
than anyone really expected and we
couldn't be more excited for what's to
come we already know that Jimmy is
destined for moral rot in a job managing
a Cinnabon the beauty of the show is how
much you don't want it to happen DC's
new take on a familiar cast of Caped
Crusader's Titans needed just two
glorious words to get fans riled up sure
Robin and the rest of the titular team
looked like they just bought out a hot
topic but critics dig DC's gritty
reimagining of the young superheroes for
instance autumn Noel Kelley at Newsweek
wrote positively about the show claiming
Titans is the most balanced superhero
show out there it skillfully constructed
narrative Lee speaking and there's a
surprising amount of flavor beneath its
classification as a dark moody teen
drama but really you know why you're
watching
[Music]